los talibanes aseguraron que respetarían
todas las opiniones afganas y que no
tomarían represalias
pero los informes de violencia e
intimidación durante las protestas
contradicen esas promesas facebook los
manifestantes pacíficos en varias
provincias de afganistán se han
enfrentado a una respuesta cada vez más
violenta por parte de los talibanes
incluyendo el uso de munición real
porras y látigos según la onu los
talibanes también intentan ocultar sus
abusos intimidando violentamente a los
periodistas se informó que a un
periodista le habían dicho mientras le
daban una patada en la cabeza que tenía
suerte de que no lo hubieran decapitado
desde su llegada al poder el mes pasado
los talibanes han tratado de presentarse
como más moderados diciendo que se
permitirá a las mujeres trabajar y a las
niñas recibir educación pero las mujeres
que sufrieron un brutal sometimiento la
última vez que los talibanes estuvieron
al mando entre
1996 y 2001 temen que el grupo no haya
cambiado
cuando los niños de las mujeres los ven
les tienen miedo porque su anterior
gobierno era muy terrible
en esta gente es muy injusta y no son
humanos en absoluto no nos dan derecho a
manifestarnos
[Aplausos]
no son musulmanes sino infieles
el grupo aún no codifica en ninguna ley
ni ofreció detalles sobre cómo piensa
gobernar pero está dando muestras claras
de que no tolerarán ninguna resistencia
contra su gobierno